it's nearing two years since the chaotic
withdrawal of U.S troops from
Afghanistan
although U.S forces evacuated tens of
thousands of Afghans thousands of others
who did not receive direct assistance
from the U.S were forced to find other
ways to leave the country
some have found themselves stuck in
unexpected places like Mexico the very
first wave was mostly people that were
connected to working with the media and
in that instance we're talking about 500
people of which I believe we helped
about 289 Transit through Mexico but we
know that that up in a window
[Applause]
since the fall of Kabul in 2021 Mexico
has seen a sharp rise in refugees from
Afghanistan
more than 1400 have been registered by
Mexico's national migration Institute
Ali is one of many Afghan refugees who
have come to see Mexico as the
proverbial final stretch before reaching
the U.S I have been in Mexico it's
almost 15 months I never thought to
leave my country I never thought I never
thought to come in Mexico after waiting
patiently in Mexico for more than a year
Ali says his U.S Asylum appointment has
finally been scheduled the look of
relief and excitement is written on his
face
but in Mexico Afghans are just some of
the tens of thousands also waiting for a
shot at requesting U.S Asylum with no
guarantees that the wait will pay off
experts say it's the result of a backlog
of Visa applications linked to a surge
in human migration through North America
human rights groups say that record
numbers of migrants transiting through
Mexico coupled with changing policies on
the U.S Mexico border have only added to
the challenges facing Asylum Seekers
and there seems to be little exception
even for the most vulnerable groups
and what is uh unfortunate is that if
there is a group of people that should
have exemplified you know that they
demonstrated that their life was under
threat that the future of their girls
was compromised after being in some ways
strategic allies uh it was this group of
Afghanistan so they became very symbolic
to many people of how the right to
Asylum is now being challenged
throughout the world
the spiraling humanitarian crisis in
Afghanistan today fueled by The Return
of the Taliban and worsening economic
conditions is causing concern over the
next wave of refugees
Al Jazeera Mexico City